screen junkies asked an actual doctor to
analyze action movies and tell us what
would really happen to your favorite
action Beals today's patient John
McClane
previously on honest action John McClane
requires four lives to complete die hard
the same should have the same guy twice
[Music]
mandible fracture shoulder contusion and
MCL tear second and third degree burns
no injuries good call
John McClain posterior root fractures
second and third degree burns
facial fractures
shoulder laceration abdominal contusions
nasal and facial bone fractures
[Music]
facial vertebrae and shoulder fractures
yippee-ki-yay
congratulations John McClane you have
survived die hard - epidural hematoma
John McClane is dead
[Music]
severe blast injuries to the lungs and
internal organs john mccain is dead
[Music]
no major injuries
good call John McClane
multiple head internal and spinal
injuries john mccain is dead multiple
internal injuries with intracranial
hemorrhage john mccain is dead shoulder
dislocation fracture
[Music]
second and third degree burns with
severe blast injuries to the lungs and
internal organs John McClane is dead
[Music]
ruptured tympanic membranes femoral neck
fracture severe road rash with shoulder
fracture dislocation laryngeal fracture
with airway collapse john mccain is dead
mandible fracture and lacerations with
glass foreign bodies lacerations with
glass foreign bodies dislocated shoulder
contusions and possible forearm
fractures orbital blowout fracture
finger fractures john mccain is dead
[Music]
abdominal contusions with internal
bleeding
[Music]
EAL lower leg femur and lumbar spine
fractures with the Rasch ballistic
humerus fracture recorder tension
pneumothorax and subclavian artery
laceration john mccain is dead pelvic
and hip fractures orbital blowout and
skull fractures with epidural hematoma
john mccain is dead multiple lacerations
and glass foreign bodies
15-plus story fall with severe brain
spine extremity and internal organ
injuries john mccain is super dead
[Music]
second and third degree burns with
tympanic membrane rupture
arm rib and hip fractures with pulmonary
contusion
[Music]
lacerations and glass foreign bodies
survival assured good call John McClane
game over
final report it would take 14 John
McClane's to survive die hard 1 through
5 you're the wrong guy in the wrong
place at the wrong time my life what
movie would you like to see us analyze
next tell us in the comments below and
we'll waste a professionals time to find
out and as always please subscribe
[Music]